the biggest and best part of the
intangible things that I was able to
take from the military would have to be
my drive to continue for
Success my name is Devon Riley I an Air
Force veteran having served eight years
in the world's greatest air force I am
from New Haven Connecticut I've been
able to work in the office of diversity
and inclusion and I've been able to
serve many different Affinity groups to
be a part of Yale's veteran Community
feels really good it's an opportunity to
see individuals who are leading the way
in different branches but as well as
different units we served and we done
some of the things at the highest level
that we possibly could I tried to live
life that way you realize Veterans Day
is a day for us do whatever you can to
make sure our community still thrives
because it it can be a little tough
always look out to other veterans we got
your
[Music]
back